since the 1960's the welcome monument
has been greeting guests to Jakarta
anyone lost in the confusion of the
narrow lanes soon gets hungry but that's
no problem
Indonesia is famed for its wire rooms
small snack bars on wheels
tsu'tey win has been making backso in
his wire room for 30 years it's a fairly
sweet dish that's what's special about
it it almost tastes like jam we'd like
to know how it's made you take fried
noodles glass noodles fried garlic and
spring onions then suin adds 2 teaspoons
of sugar and the unavoidable monosodium
glutamate but that's not all is it
now comes the sources first Samba then
ketchup Manas a very sweet soy sauce and
freshly pureed Chili Peppers
now comes the main ingredient meatballs
made of chicken and beef in a spicy
broth while we were shooting these two
young men volunteered to taste the back
so for us and what do the customers say
my snack is very popular with people
here it's tasty and cheap and as a sweet
hot flavor a helping costs about 34 Euro
cents after some 12 hours of work [ __ ]
Winn washes his utensils tidies up a bit
and makes his way home to his family
you